[Musique]
bonjour tu es mebarek bonjour bonjour
alban ivanov pad ont joué moi j'ai ça va
merci d'être sur le plateau tv 518 pour
ce vip qui vous est entièrement consacré
à tous les deux vous avez des points
communs vous êtes amis je crois jusqu'à
présent
voilà vous venez du même quartier de la
même ville absolue mais vous exercer le
même métier tout à feu voilà donc vous
venez d'un quartier de versailles
jussieu pour ne pas le nommer
ouais voilà tu aimais les et alban vous
y avez grandi tous les deux oui très
bien
eh bien oui non j'ai plein de questions
et boissons pour savoir répondre au
mieux et vous avez travaillé ensemble il
ya très longtemps
ouais c'était quoi cette histoire moi
j'ai entendu parler d'un titre not mot
molière bah ouais parce qu'à l'époque il
y avait le mois molière à versailles qui
existe toujours qui existe toujours mais
qui ne venaient pas jusqu'au quartier
bernard de juger donc on a décidé de
faire notre note molière à des jeux de
bons proposition de djamel bessa
l'humour 1-1 et dites moi c'était quoi
c'était un spectacle vivant c'était un
spa une création qu'on a fait à trois
délits non karim khalif alban et moi et
donc c'était à base d'improvisations
qu'on écrivait au fur et à mesure on a
répété quand même pendant deux mois une
succession de sketches de situations
différentes
d'accord voilà vous avez joué donc une
seule fois à jussieu seule fois la salle
était pleine
ok parce qu'en fait vous avez tous les
deux bon vous êtes tous les deux
artistes nous avait aussi tous les deux
deux fonctions importantes vos gmail
vous êtes acteur est aussi metteur en
scène
voilà est allé bon vous êtes acteur et
humoriste ou humoriste et acteur
vous avez peut-être commencer comment
ad'abord humoriste d'abord acteur et
auteur aussi les auteurs authors bien
sûr j'écris mes propres sketches
bah oui
c'est pas de la tête j'ai commencé moi
j'ai voulu commencer acteurs mais ça
marchait pas sa livrée avec pas à
l'époque et c'est ce qui fait que je me
suis dirigé vers la scène et le one man
show d'accord parce que j'en avais marre
d'attendre qu'on m'appelle mais pour le
cinéma etc c'est ça c'est en fait c'est
une fois que j'ai fait le deuil du
cinéma je me suis vraiment d'une à fond
dans la seine oui le cinéma commence à
s'intéresser à vous parce que là ils
s'intéressent bien avouer je leur avais
dit moi à l'époque et c'est drôle et
alors haut niveau comment vous en êtes
arrivé à ces métiers tous les deux vous
êtes dit toujours petit je veux être
acteur vous donner un exemple
bah moi c'était oui c'est ça j'ai
toujours voulu il y avait une odeur sur
les scènes de théâtre qui me qui me
parlait micra et puis surtout quand
j'étais au collège ou à versailles lui
de limoges collège travaux n'ont rien
annoncé nos lacs mais requiert de nos
lacs bien de nos lacs et puis là je suis
tombé sur un les conseillers
d'orientation qui m'a orienté vers la
mécanique lycée beau métier d'ailleurs
très bon quand on les aime quand on les
aime
un père je pense qu'il n'avait pas le
sens de l'orientation le gars du visage
et donc ça n'a pas marché de ce côté là
et puis comme j'ai toujours été amoureux
du théâtre donc j'ai déjà faire théâtre
d'accord vous êtes allé j'y suis arrivé
j'ai joué une pièce amateurs ensuite
j'ai fait l'épée de bois à la
cartoucherie tu es ensuite j'ai enchaîné
avec ariane mnouchkine ce qui m'a donné
beaucoup d'espoir rien ont projeté après
quoi d'accord et là où vous avez quand
on regarde votre filmographie ne sait ce
que fait déjà les films et courts
métrages les séries vous avez c'est long
comme le bras
ben je travaillais très régulièrement
ouais ben j'essaie de travailler au
mieux au plus est au mieux connaître ce
qui me passionne d'accord super et elle
en voyant comment vous est venue cette
vocation
déjà tout petit aussi comme gmail ou pas
non j'avais pas j'aime et je mets la
rigolade et moi ça parle d'une punition
de mon beau père ali saïdi qui était
animateur à fontenay le fleury et dans
un mj c est il ouvrait un cours de
théâtre d'improvisation et il m'avait
dit donc comme tu fais le con on classe
tu vas venir faire le con sur scène et à
partir de là j'ai j'ai adoré monter sur
scène et j'ai donné un sens à ma vie à
ce moment là mais sont à ma place et ma
rencontre avec gmail c'est marrant parce
que comme on n'a pas le même âge c'est à
un grand du quartier et donc on était un
jour à la piscine mon père on est à
moins donc je commence à parler à mes
potes que je voulais faire ça et tout et
il me disait faut absolument que tu
parles à gmail c'est andy smith est un
acteur voilà c'est ça et je vais
demander à l'apc de mon bureau je vais
aller le voir il m'a dit il m'a dit si
tu dois faire ce métier là on en
reparlera un jour c'est ont le destin
nous mettra sur sur la demande et donc
j'ai fait ma route et un jour il m'a dit
c'est bon on peut parler maintenant tu
es prêt c'est vrai c'est très trouvait
donc cette rencontre c'était autour du
grand bassin extérieur il y avait une
piscine à l'extérieur à l'époque mais je
me suis bien prêt bronze estime il
faisait des plongeons il conte avec ses
copains du 5e 2 5 mètres joie pas très
courageux déjà à l'époque
ce soir c'est quoi pour vous un élément
perturbateur c'est le titre de votre
spectacle vous avez loué louer pas louer
jouer jouer 1 voilà vous l'avais joué
dans plein de sales à paris en tournée
tout s'est très bien passé je sais oui
et c'est un succès vous êtes allé à
l'olympia la cigale en france partout
enfin très gros succès l'élément
perturbateur et donc c'est quoi un élève
bout déjà il a parlé c'est ce qui c'est
ce qui avait écrit sur mais sur mes
bulletins sciolla sur nous c'est un peu
mon surnom mais en vrai c'est que
compenser sur le coup ça ne faisait pas
l'airé c'est le problème de l'école
c'est que dès qu'on rende pas dans les
rangs on est mis dans une case et voilà
on veut c'est soit on réussit ou soit on
est dans la voie de garage
et quand on parle d' artistique à
l'école il n'y a pas de ça n'existe pas
en vrai
donc moi ça me faisait pas rire qu'on
m'appelle élément perturbateur et si je
l' ai repris en titre de ce spectacle
c'est pour montrer qu'il ya du positif
même dans un élément perturbateur
c'est à dire ben c'est à dire comme la
conseillère d'orientation c'est marrant
qu'on n'est pas de la même génération
mais c'est le même problème
c'est à dire que moi aussi quand j'ai vu
que scolairement il m'envoyait un bep
vente
j'ai demandé une école de théâtre et m'a
dit on m'a dit oui mais
non non j'aime bien les blonds
ok bon si on a la joie de vous avoir sur
le plateau aujourd'hui c'est pas par
hasard parce qu'en fait vous avez tous
des actus eu très très bien rempli donc
l'élément perturbateur le spectacle ça y
est ça on en a parlé
vous avez des films alors je me tourne
vers album à la fiche les bonnes
intentions
oui les bonnes ventes ont l'intention
avec agnès jaoui voilà la fiche vous
avez aussi le grand bain qui remporte un
succès un beau succès oui je marche de
banksy qui est là depuis longtemps elle
affiche un ca c'est un bon signe
moi depuis 23 octobre je croirais ça
dure ça dure et c'est un régal ce film
c'est la natation synchronisée
cette aide a l'air un peu un cv ça
paraît c'est marrant parce que le jour
où on m'a appelé pour ça je n'aurais
jamais pensé un jour qu'on propose enfin
c'est encore moi yard on pense pas
forcément en natation synchronisée
masculine normes on part maintenant
quand on regarde les autres n'ont plus
aucun ok je n'aurais pas pensé un jour
chez rachid de natation synchronisée
j'en doute mais ces intégristes dont
j'aurais rigolé principe du film oui
c'est de sauver des gens qui n'ont rien
à faire dans cette discipline et qui
malgré tout se serait de 2 ok on vous a
vu déjà avant dans le sens de la fête
aux électeurs edano versailles est
d'ailleurs tout en se et nakache joue un
serveur on vous a vu dans les mythos
c'était votre premier volet en 2011
voila voila apres d'ailleurs que ça
marche plus au cinéma je suis un gars
ben ouais après ça ça vous le pack ouais
mais du coup pour la brise a permis de
faire ce spectacle de choix et de faire
plein de choses des choses le le comedy
club
des chroniques à la radio france inter
europe 1 et plein plein de choses c'est
pas rien quand même
on sait pas a été fait ça voilà mal pour
un bien on va dire eh ben voilà un ca et
puis c'est que ce n'était pas le moment
mais là c'est un fond le moment parce
qu'il ya plein d'autres films qui vont
sortir ça y est on a qu'on vous sentez
entier encore on a besoin de tout le
monde s'arrache seulement ivana flamand
mais après c'est pareil
enfin c'est je suis je suis très content
après sa veste
l'idée mois du cinéma c'est de faire ce
qui me plaît vraiment et mais je reste
prioritaire à la scène je préfère quoi
qu'il arrive il va le cinéma mangera pas
la scène si vous voulez restigné mapfre
à manger oui ça peut mais c'est pas
cesser ces jeux c'est vraiment chouette
mais la scène n'a que ce que j'aime avec
la scène c'est que c'est toujours ce
moyen de défense de même ces personnes
m'appellent ben je pourrais quand même
joué mes sketches tout seul sur des
plans qui scène voilà il ya un côté un
peu comme le théâtre le cinéma ça vient
des sensations qui sont papas cinéma
c'est plus une récré quoi dès l'époque
on a fait tout le boulot à la maison on
y va et on va s'amuser
les camarades alors votre filmographie
elle est vraiment très longue
vous avez des films aussi qui qui sont à
la fiche qui vont sortir on devrait les
voir sur les visuels là donc vous avez
zones franches zone franche qui est
encore en mode off qui a encore montage
donc ça ça va sortir prochainement
peut-être pas tout de suite leurs
bâtisseurs mal agi avec gilles lellouche
via qui a réalisé le grand bain voilà
après qu'est ce qui est à l'affiché en
ce moment à lundi ce matin la zone
franche il y a las il y avait les les
frères ennemis de données de le fennec
reda kateb et mathieu bélie de fans vous
l'avez déjà fréquenté pour loin des
hommes ont désormais les corps gras
vient
un très beau rôle sinon tiennent leur
rôle est un très beau film houphouet
avec un débat kateb et viggo mortensen
et 100 m l'x voici chouette je le
regarde
ouais après vous êtes aussi il ya
d'autres -ismes je me sentais alors les
footeux c'est vous il y en a tellement
que c'est très compliqué pour moi qui ai
mémoire de poisson
non moi je ne viens plus comment il
s'appelle le film de mohamed hamidi je
sais tout ça parce que ça va se jouer
franchement on a les mêmes idées et
aussi le film de michel leclerc s'est
lassé de la lutte des classes la lutte
des classes mais voilà et vous allez
aussi parce que vous avez à côté metteur
en scène aussi bien une plaie j'ai bien
compris votre amour du théâtre et vous
allez mettre en scène un spectacle c'est
déjà le travail a commencé selon
ravignon réunion commence à vraiment
s'il vous plaît on démarre
dans la deuxième partie du mois de
janvier pour mettre le squelette en
place en fait de la pièce entre les deux
acteurs qui sont slimane dazi et patrick
va seillière on va aller répéter chez
patrick à barcelone pendant trois
semaines un mois
d'accord mais ensuite on va se quitter
parce que slimane a des obligations
patrick aussi et moi aussi et on se
retrouve femme et ont répété jusqu'à
avignon d'accord et cette caisse appel à
cette pièce s'appelle daniel et qu'il a
écrite c'est patrick le sol hier à
génial voilà hockey est donc là ça c'est
un grand bonheur qui va approcher je
pense aussi génial que vous adorez bah
oui moi je suis pas sur la scène je suis
là je regarde mes camarades je leur
envoie leur image et je rigole oui on
espère on veut pas dire que ça va être
drôle avant parce que c'est très
dangereux
après on vous voit aussi à la télévision
aux courses est récurrent dans candice
renoir qu est une série web
tiens là voilà quand on parle du loup
est aussi notre une autre série qui
s'appelle remix remix soit voilà au
remix de baya kasmi travers pour la 6 et
c'est avec alors j'ai noté des nous
assez sympa mais j'ai noté les noms avec
une ali haroun grégory montait lyès
salem et laura julie à pyatt on ira
christine millet françois levantal
biyouna et moi même mais génial de
regarder tout ça ce sera aussi drôle moi
vous venez donc du même endroit vous
avez réussi à faire ce que vous aimez et
je me demandais comment ce qu'est ce qui
a fait que ma vont vous avez un peu
raconter ses histoires de rencontres en
fait d'arriver avec la force de la
volonté à faire ce qu'on aime ou pas que
pourquoi tout le monde que tu es que
vous avez réussi mais je vais le de
ténacité de waimes je pense qu'on vrai
enfin d'exemple que j'ai vu de gens qui
n'ont pas réussi c'est qu'à un moment
donné ils ont abandonné mais je ne
connais aucune carrière ou route de
quelqu'un qui n'a pas lâché la sphère
qui use salle l'a pas fait à un moment
donné c'est vrai mais c'est obligatoire
sur la durée sur la durée si on aime ce
qu'on fait vraiment et puis qu'on est
sincère avec ce qu'on fait ça se voit
j'ai alors que si on hésite en tâtonnant
et puis qu'on se dit tiens comment je
vais manger comment je vais payer mon
loyer tout ça c'est des et puis on se
retire un peu on est en même temps ces
céréales
si c'est réel mais moi ça m'est arrivé
de ne pas manger de d'avoir des galères
pour payer mon loyer mais de ne pas
céder sur certains rôles que je ne veux
pas faire alors je voulais en venir à
faire donc
parce que quand on a à préparer
l'émission car cette émission est
préparé et oui messieurs vous m'aviez
dit il ya des rôles que je refuse
bah oui tout ce qui est les caricatures
tout ce qui est ce qu'on appelle nous
entre nous quand on se voit c'est les
rôles de de service
bonjour monsieur commenté va signer
mercredi une caricature énorme mais bon
donc ça non merci
c'est comme si il focaliser là dessus et
puisque tu déjà les ça suffit voilà ça
suffit largement préféré ne pas tourner
les réalisme et avec ceux qui le sont
réellement dans la hutte quoi c'est une
intéresse pas ces gens très bien
d'accord et alors j'ai regardé un
traitement encore une fois l'émission
vous avez fait un film est réalisé 1
on peut dire un documentaire dans les
yeux par les jeux dangereux sur les yeux
d'un gie cieux ouais ben c'est que
j'avais moi j'avais fait une série sur
m6 à l'époque s'appelait ma terminale
c'est un oubli fiction et c'est pour ça
que j'avais
j'ai plus jamais pris ni caméras chez
canal et boissy à l'époque je faisais
canalstreet une émission sur sur sur le
site de canal + avec issa doumbia et
donc j'avais échoué une caméra de là-bas
et j'étais parti filmer mon équipe de
foot pendant une journée à votre équipe
de deux des huit le sketch est tiré de
deux des yeux dont je suis calme lorsque
être sûr jours d'antibes le foot cac à
mourir de rire
la chine a vécues mais qui volent de
l'eau et mais quand on voit un quart
d'heure il ya une phrase que je trouve
assez forte
il ya des joueurs qui dit nous parce
qu'ils sont pas au complet ils disent on
est jamais on n'est pas aux badauds
ligue 1 et en un qui dit on va compenser
avec la rage et je trouve ça très beau
cette phrase et je pense que ça
fonctionne d'ailleurs parce que je passe
pour spolier jeu peu près le fibo ils
ont gagné quand même à 0 mesurer
l'honneur lyonnais
voilà après on les voit s'habiller dans
le vestiaire et il ya des gros plans sur
les chaussures alors il ya un gros plan
sur les chaussures à crampons donc ça
grand luxe chaussures à crampons 35
euros 100 % / / algérienne de ce voile à
la chaussure qui n'est pas du tout à
crampons plus lucia pas et qui est
complètement scratcher strappé il dit
strappé titre hop voilà
et ils jouent ils ont pas les mêmes
armes en 1100 servent de leurs armes à
feu et apparemment ça marche quoi ça ça
vous a fait un parallèle je trouve un
petit peu ça ça fait un parallèle c'est
moi je sais tu avais pensé aussi aux
grands bains cette thématique du film
moment et je pensais après c'est les
clés les ponts positif des quartiers
qu'on met pas assez en avant mais c'est
que votre quartier entre la solidarité
la débrouille
c'est le
meilleur terrain pour apprendre ça et ça
sert dans la vie de tous les jours
la solidarité ça deviendrait un
cautionner gnl sommes totalement et en
parlant de solidarité quel est votre
action au niveau du théâtre dans le
quartier jussieu mais j'en avais une
déjà les minimes là j'ai fait quatre ans
de bénévolat dans le quartier bernard de
jussieu mise à part quand j'ai me alban
scène avec karim et puis c'était déjà
des grands donc avec les petits oui on a
fait des courts métrages on a fait des
des pièces de théâtre et comme c'était
pas reconnue par la mairie de versailles
à l'époque puis que voilà ça ça servait
pratiquement à rien que je les fasse si
ce n'est à enrichir les jeunes et les
enfants
c'était la priorité donc je me suis
retiré et puis à un ami qui a pris le
relais est un chemin qui continue
jusqu'à aujourd'hui à faire les cm1 et
cm2 type voile à épiler un peu plus
grand il fait des courts métrages ils
l'ont fait à peu près un parent donc ça
fait là sa sixième jeu en tant que
comédien donc je fais je sers de le père
ou le
cool en voilà au long cours aussi bas la
palette est large et 10 4 et vous alors
le prochain spectacle
balazs hors d'âge donc je repars à zéro
voilà j'ai fait en rodage ça veut dire
que je teste dans des petites salles
ketch jeu l'écran en même temps que le
jouer ça c'est ma grande spécialité
s'est dit là bas je suis j'ai déjà des
pistes j'ai des premiers jets et après
c'est comme ça c'est les réponses ou les
choses les plus marrantes
c'est sûr que là où les gens réagissent
à son direct qu'il fallait trouver donc
vous jouez dans des petites halles à
paris n'en ont que en province voilà
j'étais à mulhouse la suite' l1 je
repars à nantes et vous tenez sur
combien de temps de spectacle moi je
fais une heure une heure vingt ah quand
même
ouais j'ai le premier spectacle en appui
oui je voudrais ajouter du foot ça fait
plaisir ça fait toujours oui ou le gitan
ou octobre d'ailleurs c'est assez drôle
parce que vous vous osez tout vous
permettez tout je parle au niveau des
clichés racistes ça va vous y aller à
fond ce n'est rien dire et est-ce que
c'est pourquoi vous permettez ça passe
d'ailleurs les noirs les renois parce
que enfin moi dans en fait sur scène je
fais autant d'efforts je retranscris
exactement mais c'est vrai que ne fait
aucun effort continu l'absence de pas je
me dis pas faut pas froisser les gens
font pas dire de gros mots
il faut pas dire ça c'est les délires
que j'ai sur scène c'est exactement les
délires que j'ai dans la vie avec mes
amis noirs arabes gitans c'est comme ça
que sa part mais en fait je veux pas
dénaturer ça c'est pour ça que dans la
pression que je me permets de faire
quelque chose sur scène mais en vrai is
love when we met au point que ce n'est
pas par hasard c'est parce que ces gens
vous les connaissez c'est oui mais après
je pense que c'est pareil aussi dans qui
je veux viser sur scène par exemple moi
j'ai pas d'enfant parce que j'ai pas je
veux pas d'enfant dans ma salle parce
que je suis où je fais pas un spectacle
pour les ont bien stipulé que c'est lié
au moins 14 mai c'est parce que après
j'aime pas non plus tout mélanger
j'adorerais faire un film pour les
enfants
demain on me dit tu fais beethoven je
fais beethoven est grand plaisir je fais
ce que tu veux mais la selle pour moi ce
qui est important c'est de détendre les
parents en fait c'est ça mon seul but
c'est que les gens qui ont des enfants
si moi j'arrive à les détendre chez qui
vont être bien chez eux et que avec
leurs enfants
je fais une thérapie ouais c'est un peu
thérapeutique et les j'adore avoir des
gens qui me disent ils ont laissé leurs
enfants à la nounou ils ont ça les a
permis de se retrouver à mon spectacle
et ben moi c'est ça qui me plaît mais
voilà de voir sortir un couple est
content de rentrer de revoir leur
enfance à l'aise et détendu ça leur a
fait du bien
c'est là dessus que je vous avez des
enfants vous même tout à fait d'accord
nous vous avez de quoi est il a vu mon
spectacle c'est bon il comprend pas tous
- mais mais c'est pas pour lui et le
prochain spectacle il va être comme ça
orientées sur des choses de la vie
quotidienne
ouais la vie khady guèye est un peu web
que ceux là mêmes formules le vécu des
choses que que
j'ai fait que j'avais pas fait avant que
je raconte comme à les choix les jouets
en prison j'ai fait une tournée des
prisons où je raconte ça tu es riche et
les matières de sympathie thouet c'est
que après voilà ça c'est un monde
après moi je recevais des slaves de tus
parce qu'on a lyon fait j'aurais pu
faire une tournée que dédié plusieurs
héros on m'a dit que telle vision 12 ha
oui pathé raison c'était juste oui c'est
ça ça parait il ya très peu de parce
qu'il ya très peu de spectacle toujours
en prison bon ça là pour rigoler je
pense c'est ça qui était intéressant
parce que même un maton ils étaient
contents de me voir mais en même temps
il n'était pas content que j'avais fait
rire hockey dans mathieu lere et ce
spectacle on sait quand il va sortir
officiellement payer tout j'ai pas le
choix il doit sortir novembre novembre
prochain bon d'accord c'est pratique
mounir à vous voir on va déjà pouvoir
tous les deux sur sur les écrans de
cinéma et a choisi un c'est très riche
un énorme merci hein vous êtes mon
cadeau de noël avant l'heure
alors c'est génial merci merci d'être
venu en valais mais l'embarras devant et
on dit j'espère un alizé un grand merci
[Musique]